[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du sky est qu un
numéro spécial du sky échos consacrent à
la responsabilité sociétale des
entreprises et pour en parler nous avons
trois invités en plateau bonjour à tous
bonjour alors on nous avons flora à tout
est chargée de projets économiques
mission innovation sociale à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines philippe brand directeur
d'établissement de la cvs 4 ap la
céleste qui en charge l'assainissement
des eaux et nous avons une grille malouf
bonsoir pense à vous êtes chargé de
recrutement chez still un design style à
une disette spécialisée dans le design
et le prototypage industriels alors on
va commencer cette émission avec une
définition de la responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises je vous
propose la définition issue de la norme
internationale iso 26000 qui décline
cette préoccupation par rapport à une
démarche de responsabilité sociétale des
entreprises une démarche qui s'organise
autour de la gouvernance de la
communauté le développement local des
droits de l'homme des questions
relatives aux consommateurs la loyauté
des pratiques l'environnement les
relations et les conditions de travail
alors je me tourne vers vous quelle est
la définition que vous avez vous de la
rs qui veut commencer je commençais
naturellement pour moi ça va être des
enjeux sociaux sociétaux et
environnementaux
c'est assez cohérent avec notre autre
métier donc c'est pour ça effectivement
que c'est important pour mieux vous
ingrid de votre côté alors nous on a la
même définition je pense tous les trois
c'est floral experte mais y'a vraiment
il ya sept piliers qui se regroupent
autour de trois thèmes
sociétales économiques et
environnementales nous chez still in
design on s'intéresse évidemment à tous
les sujets mais on peut pas opérer
sur sur les sept nous en termes de rh on
s'investit énormément dans dans tout ce
qui est sociétale notamment par rapport
à la féminisation d'insertion des
personnes
dans le bassin évidemment des saint
quentin en yvelines mais des personnes
parfois qu'ils sont un petit peu loin de
l'emploi et après évidemment on a les
démarches plus plutôt environnementale
mais ça c'est le service qualité qui en
parlera un peu plus et on va rentrer
dans les détails plus tard dans la
mission et vous flou on vient d'entendre
une grille qui dit développement du
tissu local je pense que ça ça c'est une
de vos préoccupations à saint quentin en
yvelines en tout cas fait donc
évidemment la rse donc ma demi inséré
autour des enjeux les actions mises en
place par les entreprises pour répondre
aux enjeux actuels et à venir des enjeux
sociétaux nous évidemment au niveau du
développement local ça nous intéresse
particulièrement mais c'est vrai que le
champ d'action est très large comme le
disait d'ingrid on va à la fois à lille
sur des sujets qui concernent
par exemple des actions autour du
handicap mais aussi des actions autour
donc on a dit autour de la transition
écologique ou énergétiques également
autour de la mobilité autour des achats
responsables
de l'égalité hommes-femmes
voilà les actions sont vraiment très
très large et j'en profite nous avons
voulu
observer la direction du développement
économique en savoir un petit peu plus
sur le champ d'action des entreprises
voir comment valoriser des actions et
les accompagner et nous avons lancé une
enquête en décembre dernier donc en
quête qui est toujours en ligne si
certaines entreprises n'ont pas encore
eu le temps de répondre il est toujours
temps de répondre
justement pour découvrir les bonnes
pratiques et les besoins des entreprises
pour mettre en place des stratégies
volontaires autour de la rse et dans
cette émission vous allez nous donner
les premières tendances qui se dégagent
de cette enquête justement on y
reviendra après juste une question
justement sur les enjeux que vient de
présenter flora
quel est l'intérêt pour une entreprise
justement de s'engager sur ces sujets
sont pas forcément rentable parce que ça
vous apporte pas directement une
rentabilité pourquoi les entreprises
s'engagent dans ces domaines il ya
plusieurs avantages en tous cas pour
nous pour notre métier comme vous l'avez
dit c'est le métier de l'eau et de
l'assainissement nos grands cycles de
l'eau c'est pas très connue tout le
monde ouvre le robinet on sait pas
comment lui arrive elle tombe pas du
ciel il ya beaucoup de métier derrière à
47 métiers différents donc c'est déjà
faire connaître nos métiers c'est
attirer des talents des jeunes des moins
jeunes des personnes issues des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville on a
besoin d'engager en tout cas des acteurs
et on s'est rendu compte d'ailleurs
l'intérêt pour une entreprise c'est que
accueillir dans l'inclusion des jeunes
qui ont eu des difficultés et bien c'est
une façon effectivement de les ancrer
dans l'emploi ils ont l'impression
d'être utile et se rendre service et
donc sanctions plus performants envers
nos clients et revient leur travail donc
il ya cet intérêt faire connaître ses
métiers ce sont des métiers en tension
le métier de l'assainissement est peu
connu mais en réalité on est on est sur
des métiers qui sont parfois très
techniques parfois du numérique et
parfois du social donc il y a un besoin
évidemment l'eau ne fonctionne pas tout
seul il faut des âmes des hommes est
derrière simple si évidemment c'est des
acteurs donc un enjeu humain avant tout
après c'est les valeurs de notre
entreprise on est dans le cycle
environnemental on a besoin de
contribuer d'agir sur le territoire
alors des actions concrètes et ça c'est
donne du sens aussi à nos collaborateurs
mais pas que nos collaborateurs et à nos
partenaires nos clients et on est assez
complémentaire
g steel and design vous vous êtes dans
l'industrie aéronautique automobile
quel est l'intérêt pour vous justement
de vous engager sur ces sujets
d'insertion d'inclusion alors moi je
vais dire alors des restes que j'ai pas
dit tout à l'heure c'est que la rse à la
base c'est volontariat ou une contraire
ont une contrainte juridique nous
aujourd'hui on a des contraintes
évidemment juridiques de la part de nos
clients puisque leurs clients eux
demandent à voir patte blanche sur sur
les démarches rse notamment par rapport
à l'écologie etc
donc ça on le fait parce que c'est une
demande et c'est bien ça vient
les commandes hier la tendance change
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le client
l'avenir façonner ce qu'il veut acheter
et sa force les entreprises à le faire
nous c'est pareil aussi d'un point de
vue et rage c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
on a des candidats qui vont regarder ce
que l'entreprise fait qu'est ce que j'ai
comme valeur en face de moi lorsque je
rentre en entretien lorsque je vais sur
le site internet donc du coup c'est une
démarche qu'on est au c même pas obligés
parce qu'on en a envie parce que c'est
foncièrement dans les valeurs de
l'entreprise chez style and design de
les montrer et ça donne un rayonnement
au niveau des candidats de nos clients
et les clients finaux puisque nous comme
on né du big bill et clients finaux qui
ne voient pas tout ce qui est fait
derrière et donc du coup pour moi c'est
une situation qui est c'est un win win
qui est tripartite entre entre le
consommateur les clients et les
candidats qui sont qui sont chez nous et
c'est pour ça que nous on s'engage
quotidiennement sur des petites ou des
grandes actions de rse donc là on est
dans sur des sujets vraiment
d'attractivité de rendre attractif les
emplois que vous proposez flora
justement les premiers éléments de cette
enquête comment les entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines se saisissent de cet
enjeu de rse oui alors donc pour revenir
sur cette enquête donc on a une
cinquantaine de réponse on a également
mené une dizaine d'entretiens
le but c'était de découvrir le champ
d'action donc globale mais plus
spécifiquement également au regard du
développement économique sur trois
enjeux donc l'orientation des jeunes et
l'insertion professionnelle la santé et
le bien-être des salariés et puis
l'inclusion numérique
donc évidemment l'orientation des jeunes
et l'insertion professionnelle est une
thématique qui est ressorti
particulièrement et sur lesquels les
entreprises souhaitent s'engager
de façon globale parmi toutes les
entreprises qui ont répondu 85% des
entreprises estime à la mettre en place
une dynamique ou plutôt indique mettre
en place une dynamique et une politique
rse après on pense que finalement c'est
bien plus parce que le champ est
tellement large tout le monde lassé des
actions leur et ce même si elles ne sont
pas toujours qualifiés et
identifier et étiqueter comme rse il ya
quand même beaucoup d'actions mises en
place oui parce qu'il ya des actions qui
peuvent paraître banale on le disait
ingrid par exemple accueillir des
stagiaires cueillir des alternants je
pense que c'est la même chose au sein de
la céleste chez ans ça paraît banal mais
ça rentre dans un cadre de
responsabilité sociétale des entreprises
tout à fait tout à fait et ça je pense
que vous dans votre couette c'est pareil
nous on s'engage sur sur des stages même
de troisième qui sont des stages
d'observation où on a l'impression que
c'est pas grand chose mais on investit
quand même nos collaborateurs pour leur
présenter leur métier et en fait on est
en train de semer une petite graine dans
dans la tête de chacun de ses élèves en
troisième pour c'est à dire ah bah tiens
les métiers d'ateliers finalement ça
m'intéresserait à le design tiens ça
m'intéresse et donc du coup en fait
cette connaissance elle elle germe dès
le plus jeune âge et c'est pour ça que
nous on est on est on est toujours on
accueille toujours à bras ouverts les
stagiaires de 3e c brin jaloux
typiquement c'est ce qui s'est passé la
dernière action que nous avons menées
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure des
entreprises s'engagent effectivement la
france une chance nous sommes appliqués
dans ce dispositif avait un certain
nombre d'actions et la dernière action
que nous avons menées çà a été
d'accueillir des jeunes des quartiers
prioritaires de la ville
comment attraper à côté des jeunes de 3e
qui ne trouvaient pas de stages faire
découvrir notre métier et quand on leur
a expliqué que c'était l'eau
l'assainissement une terre un petit peu
sceptique bon ils en sont repartis ravis
ils ont découvert ce qui avait
d'ailleurs du robinet ils ont découvert
des métiers et ça ce sont des actions
intéressantes et on voit bien
effectivement dans cette logique là il
ya en tout cas des progrès à faire et
notre côté en tout cas ça correspond
aussi aux valeurs de l'entreprise je
parle pas de l'environnement dans son
capital oui des progrès à faire le film
c'est à dire des progrès à faire vous en
tant que l'agglomération territoires ddt
et d'innovation saint quentin en
yvelines vous vous êtes là pour
coordonner un peu peut-être tout ça pour
justement comme le disait philippe en
aller plus loin peut-être dans les
démarches rse coordonner les actions des
entreprises et puis des différents
acteurs associatifs aussi sur le
territoire alors justement c'est ce
qu'on a essayé de faire avec une
première réaction qui a eu lieu la
semaine dernière au ski cube donc on a
rassemblé une vingtaine d'entreprises
par rapport aux enjeux qu'on avait pu
voir émerger au sein de cette enquête
suite à cette enquête à l'analyse de
cette enquête on a décidé de travailler
sur l'orientation des jeunes et
l'inclusion et l'insertion
professionnelle les premiers les
premières années avec l'organisation
d'un collaborateur donc leur
collaboration lors peut-être que vous
avez déjà entendu parler de brian atwood
hackaton il s'agit d'ateliers en
intelligence collective guidés par des
facilitateurs
donc on avait une vingtaine
d'entreprises qui sont réunis au spi
cube ainsi que des des porteurs de
solutions donc des acteurs locaux je
peux citer par exemple face avec lequel
la cbs qui est notamment
intervient femmes ingénieurs mais aussi
nos quartiers ont des talents qui
étaient présents pour apporter à la
foire leur expertise sur ces enjeux
mais aussi des solutions et faire
émerger des idées innovantes donc
c'était vraiment très mal son de pouvoir
partager sur ces thématiques avec donc
trois sous groupes un groupe sur la
féminisation des métiers scientifiques
et techniques parce que la féminisation
c'est vrai que c'est un enjeu peut-être
voudra revenir dessus également sur la
valorisation des métiers par auprès des
jeunes et savoir comment se saisir
aujourd'hui des codes des plus jeunes
pour valoriser les métiers dès le plus
jeune âge est également l'inclusion
professionnels du recrutement jusqu'aux
premier mois dans l'entreprise pour
répondre aux attentes aujourd'hui des
jeunes talents et des jeunes arrivant
sur le marché du travail alors on a on a
deux minutes trente pour aborder ce
sujet surface justement fondation agir
contre l'exclusion
quelle expérience vous allez avec cette
fondation écoutez elle est
complémentaire dans les actions ce qu'on
disait sur le territoire nous n'avons
pas la possibilité de rentrer en contact
avec les publics qui cherchent des
stages c'est la exemple que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure c'est face qui nous a mis
en relation avec le lycée youri gagarine
et les jeunes c'est dans le cadre par
exemple des job academy donc c'est
accompagné d'autres jeunes qui sont en
recherche d'emploi apporter notre
mécénat aider des jeunes à retrouver un
emploi pas forcément dans notre
entreprise dans une autre entreprise
on se rend compte que dans cette
situation est difficile effectivement de
savoir qui accompagnait d'en face met en
relation en tout cas les jeunes moins
jeunes du territoire avec les
entreprises comme nous qui sommes
engagées pour accompagner ces
situations-là ces situations donc
d'insertion ou d'inclusion et on se rend
compte et c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que spontanément au sein de
l'entreprise on a des jeunes qui qui ont
envie d'aider ils n'ont pas été aidés
eux mêmes et se disent à leur tour
qu'ils peuvent apporter ce service
auprès des jeunes et c'en est une force
aujourd'hui des jeunes que l'on recrute
sont attentifs c'est ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure soit attentif aux valeurs
qui sont déployés dans l'entreprise on
parlait de féminisation tout à leur
faire connaître nos métiers aux hommes
aux femmes je prends un exemple
auxquelles je suis attaché en tant que
entrepreneur est ce qui est important
c'est d'être engagé un c'est de faire
les choses je veux dire c'est une chose
faire les choses c'est mieux et
typiquement l'index égalité
femmes-hommes autant parle souvent il ya
dix ans paraît finalement c'est une
tendance clairement moi je suis très
fier aujourd'hui on a réussi à avoir
cette année un index de 99 % ce qui pour
moi je dirais le summum simplement ça se
fait pas tout seul c'est un travail
d'engagement de l'entreprise
d'engagement des collaborateurs des rh
et est clairement ça contribue en tout
cas au mieux-être un des collaborateurs
on efface comme ça les distorsions on
est dans le mieux-être au travail et
tout ça c'est une certaine cohérence
avec avec la rse un mot justement une
malle ou sur la féminisation parce que
vous vous êtes sur des métiers à ces
techniques on parle d'industrie on parle
de design le prototypage d'usinage aussi
c'est un ange la féminisation de ces
métiers nous c'est un enjeu est juste
pour rebondir serait ce que vous avez
dit c'est aussi un mais enfin pour nous
c'est vrai que ces drh c'est les
collaborateurs mais c'est un message qui
est porté par la direction aujourd'hui
mois de ça ça fait plus de trois ans que
je suis dans cette société et c'est la
direction qui porte aussi ce message de
on souhaite féminiser les métiers donc
du coup on a un appui derrière de la
direction et ça pour nous en tant que rh
qui sont qui sommes sur le terrain c'est
c'est vraiment c'est du pain bénit
puisqu'on peut mettre en place nos
actions qui vont passer par la
collaboration avec la task force donc
qu'ils vont mettre en relation avec
d'autres personnes qui ont les mêmes
problématiques que nous on est vraiment
dans la collaboration et ça c'est déjà
les débuts de la rse aujourd'hui on a
tous notre index qu'on n'est pas aussi
bon que vous mais on a commencé en août
à 77 aujourd'hui on est à 80 6 saisons
en attente de validation mais on est
quand même en plaine en plaine
une progression tout à fait il ya trois
ans il n'y avait aucune femme au comité
de direction aujourd'hui il y en a deux
sur sur 10 on est quand même à plus 20 %
en l'espace de deux de même pas un an et
demi on va aujourd'hui on a pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps une
stagiaire dans nos ateliers qui a qu'à
intégrer
nos équipes en modelage c'est des
petites réussites qui se voit à tous les
niveaux du stagiaire jusqu'au comité de
direction
nous les femmes quand je fais rentrer
pareil chez style et design on était
autour de 16% de femmes aujourd'hui en
avril on va être 23% c'est petit à petit
et les victoires se font aussi à des
postes de management puisque les
collaborateurs quand ils viennent dans
notre société c'est pas que voir des
femmes c'est voir des femmes à des
postes de direction de management qui
pilote des projets des ressources et ça
ça donne plus qu'un message c'est la
réalité et c'est la réalité chez style
and design on va conclure cette émission
mais avant cela quand même sujet
incontournable environnement pour un
acteur de l'assainissement l'eau on ne
peut pas ne pas parler d'environnement
sur les sujets environnementaux commence
la céleste s'engage alors effectivement
c'est le coeur de notre métier puisque
nous sommes dans ce cycle de l'eau ce
grand cycle de l'eau allant par exemple
pour puisqu'on est sur saint-quentin
donner des exemples concrets vous avez
tous persuadés étant en tout cas la base
de loisirs avec les et on qui qui sont
formidables enjeux clairement on va agir
pour réguler le niveau d'eau dans ces
bassins faire en sorte que au moment où
les oiseaux font leur nid et bien il ne
soit pas noyée par je dirais une plus
importante un orage donc on va réguler
les bassins donc là c'est un exemple
typiquement environnementale pour la
biodiversité à saint quentin ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui ça n'existait pas
il ya deux ans ça c'est un premier
exemple environnement après on peut en
apprendre plus dans notre coeur de
métier vous l'avez compris
notre métier c'est assainissement non
contenir la chasse que évidemment
qu'est-ce que ça devient on va rejeter
une eau propre à la rivière mais entre
le lavabo et la rivière on va tous
recyclés donc on va recycler les sables
qu'on va extraire des eaux usées lavage
des routes on va extraire la matière
organique pour en faire des bouts et du
compost qu'on va je dirais utilisés dans
l'agriculture donc l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir un cercle plus vertueux possible
et ça aujourd'hui c'est notre métier
évidemment on contribue de cette manière
là en tout cas à réduire le
réchauffement climatique dans la mesure
en tout cas et c'est le cas à saint
quentin voilà je vous parle de stations
d'épuration du quoi on espère faire
encore mieux parce que demain on
pourrait comme dans d'autres stations
transformer cette matière organiques en
biogaz
pour fabriquer du gaz naturel
éventuellement réchauffer et donc on
pourrait même imaginer le raccourci qui
fonctionne sur certaines usines où on va
tirer la chasse et ça produit de la
chaleur des projets donc en cours de
réflexion des projets qui sont inscrits
sur le plan climat de saint quentin et
on va accompagner les acteurs du
territoire et on a toute sa place dans
ce dispositif je crois qu'il faut qu'on
s'y mette à toussaint sur
l'environnement alors justement un
dernier mot avec vous flora tout et sur
l'environnement qu'est ce qu'est ce que
fait saint quentin en yvelines ça dépend
pas uniquement de votre direction
économique puisque fip le mentionner le
plan climat air énergie c'est la
direction de développement durable
la direction du développement durable et
des transitions
avec notamment vous pouvez trouver un
site qui s'appelle eskimos qui présente
différentes actions au niveau de la
transition écologique donc des projets
aussi inspirant
également le service des mobilités qui
travaillent sur le plan mobilité inter
entreprises et puis le cerf la mission
smart territoire avec le club climat
énergie et bien merci à tous les trois
d'être venu sur notre plateau je
rappelle flora tout et vous êtes chargé
de mission projets économiques sur
l'émission innovation sociale à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines philippe grands directeurs
d'établissement de la cvs cpt2 trappe et
ingrid malouche a chargé de recrutement
chez still in design merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission une émission que vous
pouvez revoir en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
faux